hiver dans la montagne hiver de vacances
pour cette rencontre des élégances André
ledou a créé érable où la blancheur du
manteau contraste avec le noir du fuseau
en tricotine ensemble chaud et
confortable pour les longues promenades
en traîau à travers les
sapins pour celles qui aiment la
griserie des descentes des modèles plus
strict
[Musique]
s'imposeront femm qui s'occupe
paisiblement à édifier un débon bonhomme
de neige ont préféré onyx de Gers noir
barré d'une bande jaune et kioca
ensemble l'après-midi en lainage
écossais vert jaune et
[Musique]
bleu quant à Blanche Neige de gabardin
cuir vert et Popa de tein ils ont été
réalisés par André ledou pour la joie
d'être belle pour la joie des horizon
clair